internet tisse peu à peu sa toile dans
les écoles françaises ainsi près de
trouville dans le calvados une école les
connecter un village virtuel une manière
originale d'apprendre l'histoire une
français la preuve haussier qu'internet
peut être utile mais il n'est pas
toujours facile de convaincre les maires
des petites communes nicolas le mariner
ray de deux crans à l'école de sainte
etienne la thillaye internet c'est un
grand bond dans le passé chaque semaine
les cm1-cm2 visitent le site danville
accords beline un bourg imaginaire où le
temps s'est arrêté en 1866 les enfants
dialoguent avec les habitants du village
et il faut tout expliquer à félicien
l'agriculteur ou henry l'aubergiste
cet ordinateur un cahier de brouillon
portes de 1 trouver les mots justes
formuler des phrases correctes la
correspondance impose un gros travail
d'expression écrite en classe et aussi
une recherche documentaire il ya tout le
côté aussi recherche qui font sur
internet qu'ils font sur le site dans
vie qui font dans la bibliothèque dans
les dictionnaires et qui leur permet
aussi de d'apprendre plein de choses et
l'autre côté de l'écran des animateurs
bénévoles jouent le rôle des habitants
du village leur tâche apporter une
information historique aux élèves
convaincre les petites communes
d'adopter internet n'est pas une chose
face thierry lâcherait supervise le
programme en vie c'est un pilier de
l'informatique à l'école dans le
calvados village après village on lui
pose les mêmes questions à quoi ça va
servir est-ce bien rentable d'investir
une partie
non négligeable 10 ans du budget
communal dans l'achat d'un ordinateur
pour ce qui est du coup le conseil
général du calvados payent la moitié du
matériel thierry lâcherait lui répond
aux inquiétudes des mères
informatique c'est quoi après pour les
uns pour les enfants pour des gamins un
ordinateur fait quoi
à saint-etienne l'informatisation a
coûté quinze mille francs seulement 90%
des écoles de la circonscription de
trouville sont reliés au net en france
fin 2001 tiers seulement accéder au web